let's talk about vegas what
happened how did it end up coming so
down to the wire like the night before
how did that happen i tried my hardest
right i really thought i would be able
to pull something else together you know
in time and that was why it was so last
minute which you know i regret obviously
that i kept going with it until that
late in the day
um but it was just it just wasn't ready
and there were lots of different reasons
of why there were covered you know
delays with pieces of the show there
were some things that weren't going to
be arriving until the day of the show so
therefore i would never be able to see
them or approve them
um so that you know there were lots of
delays for that we our manpower was down
because i'm doing all this testing for
my you know for my crew and stuff like
that and our carpenters who are there to
fix and change things you know there and
then we had like hardly any able to come
to work
and it just would have been a really
half-hour show and i can't do that i
can't that doesn't
people will see straight through me up
on stage
being like she doesn't want to be doing
this and that's not i've never done
anything like that in my life i'm not
going to start now you know so
obviously gutted but we're working our
asses off literally 24 hours a day i
don't want to announce a new set of
dates until i know that everything will
definitely be ready can you imagine you
don't do it again
go on and do a show that ain't ready and
i don't know i don't want it but i have
to oh yeah but but also i suppose when
we think about you we think about you
know this voice and you kind of think if
it was just you a piano a light bulb but
a mic yeah people would have been quite
happy was it was that ever a possibility
that you'd just go out and kind of go
look guys there's nothing there's def
there's nothing
there's me no there's definitely there
is a you know there is there was a part
of the show that was like that but i i
feel like i've always had a really great
incline with my show like you know i'm
really comfortable in theaters which is
one of the reasons i'm so bloody excited
about doing the coliseum yeah and then i
nailed my arenas i don't care what no
one says like specifically that i'd
always done theaters and i went on every
night loving doing my show because i
knew it was a great show like you know
and then i did stadiums and i did it in
the round which even my team were like
worried about i thought for a solo
artist i thought bloody nailed it i
worked the whole time
but it was also like it was it was just
it was a stadium show but we'd been on
tour for so long with you know with the
arena tour and stuff like that and um i
don't wanna i just i'm not going to try
and do a stadium show in in theater but
it's vegas it can't just be me on my
[ __ ] guitar
something else happening you know it's
not completely not not the whole show
stripped back no and uh and so you would
say you are planning to do these they
are going to happen absolutely they are
watching 100 happening okay yes and how
long might fans have to wait i'm not
asking for commitment to a date but just
you know if you have a ticket are you
holding on to that for years
this
[Applause]
i have plans next year
imagine if i have to cancel shows
because i'm having a baby
no i've got plans next year
that is some gestation
[Music]